IMPERIALISM AND FIGHT FOR A JUST
WORLD.
>> Dana: GREG, WHAT KIND OF
WORLD IS SHE THINKING ABOUT?
GREG WHEN I HEAR HER, I THINK,
"OH BROTHER."
BERNIE SANDERS TALKING ABOUT
IMPERIALISM, RIGHT?
TALKING ABOUT IMPERIALISM.
REALIZES THAT HIS SOCIALIST
HEART IS NOT IN SWEDEN OR
DENMARK, IT'S IN SOVIET BLOC OR
CUBA.
HIS IDEAS ARE KIND OF
DESTRUCTIVE.
WHEN YOU ACCUSE OF ANYBODY,
LIKE, YOU DON'T LOVE AMERICA,
WHEN WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
AMERICA AS SOME KIND OF WESTERN
IMPERIALISTIC MASS, THERE IS A
VALID POINT TO BE MADE THERE.
>> Dana: THEY CAN'T WAIT TO
SEE AMERICA FUND MENTALLY
CHANGED.
>> Jesse: I WILL SAY THE REAL
WESTERN IMPERIALISTS ARE THE
FRENCH OF THE BRITISH WHO IN
SCREWED UP THE ENTIRE MATH.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MIDDLE EAST,
THEY ARE THE ONE WHO DREW UP ALL
THE LINES WE ARE DEFENDING.
COME ON, BRITISH!
READ: WAY TO STICK IT TO THE
BRITS
>> Emily: PEOPLE IN VENEZUELA
ARE BUYING GAS FOR CIGARETTES.
IT'S RIDICULOUS AND THIS IS WHY
PEOPLE LAUGH AT HIM AS
EVENTUALLY BEING THE MAINSTREAM
CANDIDATE WHEN YOU THROW AROUND
WESTERN IMPERIALISM -- IT'S
NEVER GOING TO HAPPEN.
NEVER BEEN FURTHER AWAY IN MY
LIFETIME, SHE'S A REFUGEE
>> Juan: IS IN TRUMP THE ONE
WHO TRIES TO GET US OUT FIRST.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IMPERIALISM
AND IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME, HEY, I
DON'T LIKE THIS NATION BUILDING
STUFF.
I DO NOT LIKE THE IDEA WE GET
INVOLVED AS THE WORLD'S
POLICEMAN.
THIS SOUNDS LIKE THE LEFT-WING
VERSION OF TRUMP TALKING POINTS.
>> Greg: YOU ARE SAYING THAT
THEY ARE ACTUALLY PARTS FROM
2020.
>> Juan: YOU ARE SAYING IT'S
OUTRAGEOUS BUT IN FACT IT SOUNDS
LIKE YOUR GUY!
>> Greg: FAIR POINT.
>> Dana: WITH 2020 ELECTION,
JOE BIDEN RAISING EYES BROWS
SAYING HE DOESN'T HAVE TO WIN IN
THE CAUCUSES.
IF HE DOESN'T WIN IOWA IT
DOESN'T WIN NEW HAMPSHIRE'S --
>> Greg: IT'S WHAT YOU CALL A
LOSER.